foreign
comes from Jeremy in Arizona I'm having
a mini dilemma over my finances and
could use a neutral third party I have
some student loans to pay off and I
could have it all paid off by now but I
held off when I thought I could qualify
for Biden's student debt relief plan I
was prepared for that possibility and am
still able to pay off my remaining
balance I've heard that the Biden
Administration is supposedly working on
another Avenue for debt relief while I
know logically that paying off my debts
sooner rather than later is the Smart
call I know there's a part of me that
will feel cheated
if I pay these loans now and find out I
would have been approved for Relief
later I feel like I know what you'll say
but as I said I'd feel better to hear it
from a neutral third party I don't know
that I'm neutral I just think that you
need to pay your bills off you need to
pay your student debt you've got the
money sitting there pay your debt
there's no relief coming
there is no relief coming I'm telling
you the release the only relief there is
is 30 years from now when you're about
to retire and you've worked your whole
life paying and then maybe just maybe
there's a small chance depending on who
might be an administration at that time
depending on who might decide that they
want to make themselves look good
politically there might be a sliver of a
lightning bolts chance that you might
get a little bit of forgiveness
who wants to live their life like that
not me I like Dave I like being in
control of my life I like knowing that
if Jade says she's gonna do it she's
gonna do it I will not and you shouldn't
either live your life with this debt
hanging over your head because when you
do this and this is not just to Jeremy
this is to anybody who's holding on to
debt thinking that there's a a sliver of
a chance of a possibilities chance that
you might get forgiveness you your body
feels that
your body knows you're in debt uh Dr
John would say it all the time your body
keeps the score you know when you've got
fifty thousand dollars in debt that's
why a hundred thousand dollars of debt
that's why even these uh these payment
plans that they have set up and they're
telling you hey it's okay you can just
pay 12 a month and the interest rule in
accrue you think you can't feel the fact
that you still owe a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars of debt absolutely and
let me tell you what else you can feel
Jeremy
um the guy who's out there that's a
welder
uh the gal that's cutting hair
they shouldn't have to pay your bill
you know who pays it if you don't
taxpayer
they didn't sign up for your debt you
signed up for son
you pay your bill you owe it you owe it
it's a moral and an ethical obligation
you need to pay it
quit waiting around the government to
fix your life
10 years from today 20 years from today
you will be where you are based on who
you count on do you count on your
efforts and God's blessings or do you
count on Washington D.C the people that
count on Washington DC their life sucks
if you sit around and wait on the
government to fix your life you're going
to be standing in the DMV line the rest
of your life
that's stupid
your night doesn't work waiting on
politicians to deliver the goods
you will be waiting on your deathbed for
it
they just don't do it let me tell you
who delivers the goods Jeremy you do
get up off your assets and go to work
and pay your bill you owe it
and that guy who's a welder that gal
who's cutting hair she don't owe your
money and she shouldn't have to pay it
the taxpayer shouldn't carry your burden
you're not poor
you're just leaning towards socialism
because some stupid college professor
who studied more Karl Marx than he has
capitalism influenced you at some point
that's a word you got to get off of it
pay your dadgum bill it's that simple